hello my name is Evan R Garces I'm going
to talk about Geographic visualization
so if you have the area that you think
you can visualize on a map by using
geographic functions this is a talk for
you
I am Avenue Garces I work for some
research and I'm going to present you
some terrific with the research on
functions essentially how to plot datum
the on the maps the first thing I'm
going to show you is of course the
background for where the data is going
to be plotted we need a background is
essentially a geographic subject so
probably you already have been in Jose
or Francisco stocks they told us about
the this object or this function that
essentially give us a map of could be
the region we are in for instance this
is the map of champagne or a country
let's say the US a city for instance
this one is the map of Tokyo or a
polygon I mean it could be a country a
city or even a zip code so essentially
the the background with the data is
going to be plotted is a geographic
subject like those presented here the
the way we manipulate the this graphics
object is by using options so for
instance this option we have just scale
bar we are showing here the country of
Andorra and this is showing us the Euro
scale bar of five kilometers right so
there are different options that we can
use for the controlling the output of a
very basic map for instance we have here
the country of Peru and and then we are
showing the grid lines those are the
Latin latitude longitude lines by
separated by the angular degree of the
so Germany options for for Geographics
but those are they they made an exchange
essentially we use we are going to use
for plotting data an important one is
your range
that essentially gives us the option to
show the map of a range of a country or
probably we could we we want to have a
latitude longitude ranges but okay it is
example I don't have it here hmm
we can also change the background we
have different types of backgrounds of
course we we could have non labels we
could have just the borders of the
countries and also we have a satellite a
satellite views Francisco showed some
more details about this kind of
different backgrounds we could have and
another important one is your projection
as you can see there are different your
projections of the world shown here but
we have several of them so it's it's
just an example of how different
projections we can have in the game in
in the plot of the map okay um you we
have you will see solution primitives as
you probably know if you were in in Jose
stock we can have a geo path is
essentially a point and in a duration or
angle and and you do have a map of how
how long will you go with you if you go
to the right direction we have yo disks
your circles these this one is to
hemisphere that is showing us
if we Center the point at Mexico City
how should the map hope see the world or
legs from that perspective and this one
show was only the region of the world
that is in the night when I made this
this image it was working in the night
so that's why it's night here right yeah
so those are primitives on and are the
tools were going to use to blow data
into them okay so the first one is
Julie's plot basically it's a function
that receives a set of the opposition
inputs or entities with some position
associated for instance here we have the
largest city in the USA and we are
showing with points where those cities
are located and in this example we have
a new position object that has about
26,000 points of some trees in in
Champaign so I here is a map of those
points and we're plotting them right so
we we can also plot not only points we
can plot polygons
regions so in those examples we are
showing the countries of Europe and here
we are showing three different sets of
of countries so we have a different
color separated so the oldest plot not
only is used for plotting points but
also for showing trillions right the
second function
let's see some kind of associated to-do
list plot is your histogram we also have
set of points but we are not showing the
location of those points
we are showing the histogram both of
those points so for for the default
behavior of this function we have
external bins
so each bin is showing us an area of
champagne and if we put the mouse into
those bins we we have shown the number
of how many trees are over those area
right but of course we can change the
setting of the of the beans we have
rectangular bins triangular bins or we
can change the size of the default
hexagonal bins or triangular beans this
one is showing us I mean but the the
quantity of each bin is 1000 accros
right so that's you histogram sure there
are some sample here okay yeah so there
are different ways we can input the data
into your historian for instance here we
are we are showing the the the
population of major city
I mean cities in Europe and here we are
showing the the same data right so your
histogram is not only a histogram of
points you can also associate the region
to the quantity or to a number right
yeah so the bins can be also a country
or a polygon zip code or the polygon or
faceting etc I mean it's not limited to
just hexagons or rectangles
like in this case those are the same
data but the bins are different okay
that's a historian now we are going to
do reading value plot the main idea of
this visualization function is associate
one entity with a position and then one
value so we are showing here three
countries associated to the three
different values and each one is color
it with with a different color right in
this example we are showing the the per
capita income of different counties in
end of states in USA so that's what is
useful Georgian value plot right okay
there are some other ways to visualize
data like in the region value plot I
mean having entities with some value
associated but instead of colors we
might want to have visualization like a
locking bubble chart right so we have
geo bubble chart new and 11.1 those are
entities and values associated that can
be plane values or quantity values so
here we have the population of countries
in South America interesting example
that I am it here is the magnitudes of
last earthquakes in the last few years
in the zone of Mexico right so we are
using here call-outs as you can see the
the data is rapid by by by some
call-outs you we have
this call-out that is a new
functionality for for charting functions
so I'm showing here those recent
earthquakes that happen in Mexico by the
way this was what really what early
strong this one okay um following with
the with examples we can also have
different types of elements for geo
bubble chart not only bubbles but we can
have for instance pie charts this
example shows the farm lined area of
each state in the USA so as you can see
well well the yellow area is there the
land that is not a farm so you can see a
lot of course keV has very very very few
farm land area right and we have a
Nebraska here that I think is is the
country I mean is the state of the
country that has most the more land area
so this is showing how can we convert
bubbles into different objects and the
size of the object is going to be
proportional to the value we have
associated to the to the bubble size
right the the farm land area
right right because the the data if I
didn't show pie charts I will show
bubbles and the value stated to which
entity is the area of the state so
that's why las calles bigger than the
than the others and here we have Texas
here bigger than the others and and and
so on so this new function supports many
kinds of inputs a if you if you have the
this presentation and your laptop's you
can prove that those five different
inputs at represented the same data so
the output is going to be the same right
okay now as you probably have seen in
other visualization functions we can use
show to combine different outputs so in
this case I'm showing how we can combine
an output from the histogram here we are
showing the the number of students of
the Ford School District of champagne
so each it should be in is showing how
many students are there and the second
geography's output is the geo marker of
the position of each one of the schools
and we might want to show how do they
look like together so we are showing
we're using shout to mix the histogram
and the other markers and we can do this
with more more functions
I mean we can combine two or three or
more functions in
in the same map finally I'm going to
show that's an experimental function for
11.2 something that's a dynamic
Geographics and this is basically a
function that allows us to interact with
with the map and the output is a map
that can be pumped and assumed so those
are the buildings of New York and the
position of of those buildings and we
can interact it we can interact with
this by clicking here as a zoom okay
well
it let me just try it
I'm not sure how many many times when it
won't take because um I tested this one
before they talk but anyway meanwhile do
you have any questions yeah
remember think so that could be
different a different plot
yeah Yeah right
yeah that that's going to be a different
project yeah we don't have still that
function but
yeah
now III I wanted to tell with it yeah
that does the next next function in the
pipeline so okay so we we have a cloud
of willing healings here but I've I want
to go into those buildings I just click
here and then I can get a of course a
retiling of of the map of my Hatton and
so on and I think that that's it
let's go up here thank you
[Applause]